muy buenos días para todos ustedes pues
Uruguay está obligada a ganar si quiere
tener un poquito de chances de poder
pasar a la siguiente ronda porque las
cosas no es tan fáciles en ese grupo al
mismo tiempo va a enfrentarse a gana un
partido que tiene un poquito una sed de
revancha por parte de las estrellas
negras que recuerdan aquella aquellos
cuartos de final en 2010 cuando Uruguay
los sacó de la competición hubo una
tarjeta roja para Suárez que con la mano
sacó un balón que iba a hacer gol de
gana finalmente terminaron eliminados en
la tanda de penales Así que hay sabor de
revancha en ese partido y por el otro
lado está el partido entre Corea del Sur
y Portugal los lusos que ya están en la
siguiente ronda ahora lo que necesitan
Es simplemente quedar primeros de este
grupo para evitar a Brasil en la
siguiente ronda y bueno Corea del Sur
que tendría que ganar también a como de
lugar y luego ya nos quedan los otros
dos partidos que vendrán ya a terminar
este este día y toda esta fase de grupos
tendremos Entonces el partido de Brasil
que ya pues buscará ser primera mientras
que las cosas pueden ser un poquito más
apretadas entre Suiza y Serbia que
buscarán a como dé lugar ya quedar
segundas en este grupo sí posible otros
sudamericano es Brasil que va contra
Camerún por el primer puesto del grupo y
que esperar de este partido Natalia
Bueno pues Espera que Brasil salte a la
Campo digamos ya con un equipo B porque
va a dar un poco de descanso a su a su
titular estelaron que cuando uno mira
los jugadores que hay en el banquillo
Pues en realidad que hay otro set de
estrellas Dani Alves entraría a jugar
como el lateral derecho también estaría
Anthony que de hecho en el primer
partido entró por Neymar cuando salió ya
lesionado y como les decía pues Brasil
que va a buscar simplemente quedarse con
la primera Plaza de ese de ese grupo
Camerún Pues que la puede tener muy
difícil para poder ganarle a la canariña
pero que bien podrían dar el golpe como
hemos visto que hay dos selecciones de
africanas clasificadas una es Marruecos
y la otra esa senegal Así que veremos a
qué ocurre el día de hoy